l’époque des mauvais garçons des plus
c'est le même des beatniques est en
train de passer il reste quelques minets
et minettes et surtout des jeunes comme
tous les autres
[Musique]
tout a commencé très discrètement avec
une sono étouffée au fond d'une cave à
l'entrée presque secrète mais cela a
bien fini par se savoir cela se passe au
coeur de Belleville sous les verrières
1900 de l'ancien Palais du Commerce
[Musique]
allez-y bidons l'oignon
de la file des voitures de 4 saisons
[Musique]
et puis tout de même on a commencé à se
poser quelques questions sans méchanceté
[Musique]
parce que moi ça me va pas moi
à dire le vrai il en faut beaucoup pour
surprendre les belles Villois et la mini
jupe et les maxi cheveux sont trop dans
le vent pour que les copains de
Belleville ne soient pas depuis
longtemps au parfum mais quand on voit
le 16e remonter la pente pour venir
s'équiper aux boutiques inspirées
directement de cannabis Street ils
découvrirent le dernier gadget à la mode
on s'étonne tout de même un peu pour
l'heure ce sont les fameux badges qui
permettent d'exprimer avec une
discrétion toute relative une opinion
peut être provisoire sur les grands
problèmes du monde
en anglais afin que le temps nécessaire
à la traduction ménage un répit au
pudeur offensés
[Musique]
mais que se passe-t-il donc à Belleville
je cherche
alors c'est une nouvelle ligne les
tailles ne sont plus hautes c'est des
formes qui descendent beaucoup plus bas
faut pas avoir d'effet cet hiver mais on
peut avoir des seins peut avoir des
seins
c'est le maître des lieux qui parlent et
la bonne parole se propage du haut de la
ville jusqu'au quartier dit élégant
là ça fait un effet sensationnel
de toute manière
c'est que la morphologie des femmes
changent avec la mode quand il faut
avoir très peu de seins n'en n'ont pas
et quand il en faut beaucoup elle se
débrouille et elles en ont
très très bien
tu as fait martien curieusement côté
homme la tendance s'affirme plus
nettement encore
et à fleurs vous en avez pas à fleurs
ça se fait plus la fleur c'est fini hein
l'étang du tailleur de papa sont révolus
on va si vite qu'on en est déjà remonter
jusqu'à la redingote d'arrière-granda
dans les boutiques sages du Faubourg du
Temple on ne s'étonne plus désormais et
l'on vend de l'audace fleurit en 140
dollars comme on le faisait de la serge
sobre ou de la rayure discrète ici même
où il n'y a pas si longtemps la java
accueillait les mauvais garçons débarque
désormais en minibus les orchestres
anglais sous un sigle dans le vent
attention à toi 1 2 3 pour les balances
oh là là là là
l'époque des mauvais garçons n'est plus
c'est le même des beatnik est en train
de passer il reste quelques minets et
minettes et surtout des jeunes comme
tous les autres
[Musique]
la stéréo entre deux orchestres quelques
caisses de jus de fruits très peu de
slows encore moins de romance on vient
ici comme on conduirait à 6000 tours une
voiture de sport si on en avait une
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait du bien et après on sent mieux
surtout ça ne fait de mal à personne
au fil des heures c'est une scène
fatigue qui commence à attaquer les uns
et les autres tandis que la salle de
Bâle elle-même prend des airs et des
odeurs de gymnase
au petit matin Belleville se retrouvera
tel qu'en elle-même
a le même domicile que les moineaux qui
nichent sous les ponts chacun le sait
dans le coeur de Belleville la petite
fleur bleue pousse mieux profondément
quand il y aura du soleil sur la vie il
y aura de l'amour au cœur des belles
îles noirs
[Musique]